الى رام الله مع هناك مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد اسرائيليا كيف تتابع هذه
الجلسه الاولى وحتى الان هذه المرافعه
القانونيه لوفد دوله جنوب
افريقيا متابعه على كافه المستويات ووسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه تقوم بنقلها والتعليق
والمتابعه كذلك متابعه على المستوى
السياسي في اسرائيل وهذا يبرر مدى
الاهتمام اسرائيل قلقه من مجرد انها تقف
متهمه في المحكمه العدل الدوليه بجريمه
الاباده الجماعيه اسرائيل كانت من اوائل
الدول الذين وقعوا على اتفاق منع الاباده
الجماعيه عام 48 ومن ثم انضمت الى هذه
المحكمه في عام 51 عندما تم تاسيسها
واصبحت نافذه واعتقدت في حينه بانها جاءت
على خلفيه قضيه الهولوكوست المحركه
النازيه لذلك انضمت اليها ايضا كي تظهر
للراي العام الغربي انها شريكه لهم في قيم
الديمقراطيه والحريات وحقوق الانسان وما
شابه انذاك انضمت وكانت مناصره والان تقف
متهمه لذلك هي قلقه بشكل كبير لكن ما
دفعها الى المشاركه هي صحيح انها موقعه
على هذا على الوثيقه الخاصه بمنع الاباده
الجماعيه و ودوله جنوب افريقيا كذلك موقعه
لكن ما دفع اسرائيل هي ثلاثه اسباب اولا
انها طرف موقع وعضو فيها ثانيا من اجل ان
تظهر للراي العام الغربي انها ما زالت على
موقفها مشاركه في هذه الامور والامر
الثالث وهو الاهم هي تدرك جيدا بان العرض
المكثف والمركز لكل ما جرى في قطاع غزه
الذي قدمته جنوب افريقيا في مرافعتها هو
امر يؤثر على الراي العام الغربي ويؤثر
على الراي العام الاسرائيلي الان العام
الراي العام الاسرائيلي ربما للمره الاولى
هناك مواد كثيره شاهدها وتصريحات قادته
ايضا مقلقه له بشكل كبير وامر اخر هو من
اجل تسهيل مهمه استخدام الولايات المتحده
لحق النقض الفيتو في مجلس الامن فيما لو
تم اتخاذ قرار بوقف اطلاق النار ولو قرار
احترازي وحول للتنفيذ الى مجلس الامن كي
يتم اسقاطه في هناك اسرائيل غدا تحاول ان
تظهر نفسها انها بمقام من يقوم بالدفاع عن
نفسه في كل هذه الحرب وفي مرافعتها ستكون
هناك
ثلاثه امور خاصه بهذا الشان اولا ستعلن من
خلال الطاقم الذي سيمثلها وهو برئاسه
البروفيسور ملكولم شواو وهو بروفيسور
صهيوني يهودي بريطاني مشهور في مجال
القانون الدولي و لديها ايضا قاض وهو من
حقها كما كان لجنوب افريقيا ان يمثلها في
مجموعه في طاقم القضاه الاساسي هو 15 لكن
يضاف اليه ممثلين عن كل دوله فلديها
القاضي المعروف دوليا وهو اهرون براك من
كان الرئيس الاسبق للمحكمه العليا ويعتبر
القانوني رقم واحد في اسرائيل ويقابله ب
من جانب جنوب افريقيا القاضي ديكين موسكا
لذلك اسرائيل ستركز في مرافعتها على ثلاثه
امور حسب ما رشح عن هذه المرافعه وهو انها
اولا اضطرت على الحرب بعد مذبحه السابع من
اكتوبر الذي قتل فيها اكثر من 1200
اسرائيلي واقتطف اكثر من 250 حسب التعبير
الاسرائيلي الوارد فيها ثانيا ستدعي ان
الاقتباسات المرفقه بالشكوى التي قدمتها
جنوب افريقيا هي خارجه عن سياقها ومن
قالها ليس في دائره صنع القرار في اسرائيل
النقطه الثالثه ستكون التركيز على انها في
هذه الحرب انما هي تحارب حركه حماس فقط
وليس الشعب الفلسطيني هذه الثلاث محاور
التي ستركز عليها في هذه المرافعه لكن
واضح ان اسرائيل فعلا قلقه جدا لان هذا
محفل دولي هام جدا احد اهم المؤسسات في
الامم المتحده قراراته قد لا قراراته قد
تكون غير قادر على تنفيذها لكن هناك ك
الامم المتحده ايضا فيما اذا لو كانت هناك
متابعه
وا ومواصله لهذه القضيه ككل والتقرير الذي
قدمته جنوب افريقيا زاد من قلق
الاسرائيليين وفق ما تابعته من تعليقات
لان هناك تركيز مكثف او تكثيف مركز على
كافه التصريحات الاسرائيليه ومدعمه ايضا
باشرطه فيديو وبينات بصريه ايه قادره على
التاثير
على على طاقم القضاه وايضا على الراي
العام الان ناتي لماذا جنوب افريقيا تقدم
هذا الملف عن الفلسطينيين او عن العرب
قاطبه هذا يعود لاسباب تاريخيه بالاساس
لان جنوب افريقيا عندما كانت تحت حكم
الفصل العنصري الابرتهايد كان نظام
الابرتهايد مدعوم من اسرائيل وكان نيلسون
منديلا ودسم توتو المعارضين وال الذين
يقاومون هذا ذلك كانوا مدعومين بالاساس من
منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه فهذا يلعب دورا
هاما في كل هذه القضيه التي نشاهدها الان
وهذا موقف مفصلي في مسار الحرب شكرا وليد
العمري من رامل